no I could do it I promise I could do it
wait again Steven his trying to become a
kpop star Oh area I really want to be a
kpop star okay cool this is my lifelong
dream to be a kpop star you have to have
a certain swag about you and Steven has
just not bad Steven what have you gotten
yourself into I'm just kidding or Emma
you have to know how to dance I feel
like you can't just pick that up let
alone sing and become super stylish like
come on man
Stephens a great guy but now it's
impossible if he couldn't pull off
something even like an iota of what it
is to be kept up start with this project
then I commend him because it's
difficult it is a hard life my name is
Amber I'm in a group called FX I
recently just released two songs one is
called need to feel needed and the
second one is called on my own way
papads I guess definitely more than just
the genre of music it's passionate or
show performance aspects this whole
experience that I think a lot of people
have come to love and appreciate Steven
I've no idea what you got yourself into
but um you know never give up check your
little butt and um do something crazy
good luck Steven with amber cheering me
on I was ready to begin my quest
training like a kpop star for one week
so I called up a former kpop training to
help me get started I'm Edie I used to
do training in a Korean entertainment
agency a few years about kpop training
life is very difficult and it's really
intense so an average day for a kpop
training all these things are really
clearly regimented if you have work
you'd go to work and then afterwards
you'll probably have to do language quad
because it's kpop so you need to know
how to speak Korean yes in Korean is in
you probably go to vocal class cuz you
need to be in there best condition for
your vocals right
and then once that's over you go to
dance class open tap me push drop but
the most difficult thing about it is you
don't really have a personal life beyond
the training thing so like you'll be
doing hours of training and all aspects
especially if you want familiar with it
I think the people that make it to the
end are the people that put the most
effort okay I'm gonna put my heart into
this - Korean 101 do you know any Korean
work my friend was used to say this a
lot hi my name is Aaron Beaton I'm an
acoustics or hip-hop musician I will be
your vocal coach how you doing today I'm
okay I don't think at the end of these
confidence first thing is there's a
warm-up that is very very good for
pronunciation and the structure of your
mouth
go go go go go each other good good good
good good good good
there it is I hear sometimes kpop it's
literally building a singing dancing
machine bro I'm Michael this is Danielle
we are kpop choreographers what we want
to do is kind of see where we're at
so can you bust out with a few moves
right now yeah right now right now
here's my go-to move
now I'm gonna teach you how to introduce
yourself no Theo tonin Steven need that
hey it could be a little bit better if
you push that out a little bit more like
a baby do it a little bit of some simple
groove like a lean back oh maybe even
like licking your lips just for that
fanservice
yeah not too much oh thank god my friend
locksmith you wrote this song for me to
perform maybe um me hell night they've
talked and oh yeah and pop your knee
forward what is your favorite part of
the song when they see English yeah
okay baby uh-huh you and me you that was
I don't know where that came through
that was nice what is gonna be your
Korean name Slim Shady five books on
[ __ ] Blanco it just gets right to the
point so we're actually at a time right
now thank goodness so next session we
will be teaching you the choreography
thank you see you tomorrow
no proffer oh man okay it's like
midnight right now I have to study my
Korean probably some of my dance moves
and also try to memorize all these
lyrics I'm kinda feeling overwhelmed
these are practice a lot last night yes
I practiced all night nice
nice tall thing in the shower just
warning perfect you get that nice echo
everything sounds good oh yeah Taiana
okay
nope but then I recorded myself and hey
that oh whoa baby you and me Tina how
did about yeah you you you you you you
you you you no no I knew this would be
emotionally exhausting but I had no idea
how exhausting it would actually be how
do k-pop stars do this I don't wanna do
this anymore people told me that our
group SX is extremely like unique and
you know different but our group's goal
is just always just to be ourselves and
try to try new things and experiment
with different types of performance
aspects so we're just gonna do our thing
into the 30 minute workout I'm exhausted
but I feel pretty good
they will now double toll destiny you go
way better than last time you say I like
faster and yeah I can tell you practice
a lot baby you and me hey oh now devil
to destiny
yeah they know
oh my gosh I just sang and danced this
entire song correctly for the very first
time it took six and a half days but it
is I am Nicole and this is Christine
today we're here to style Stephen into a
kpop star from head to toe to descry
Stephen Tsai in one word it would be
very plain natural boring gray brown I
don't know I really think that she
dresses like everybody else
yeah no that's not mean I cannot being
honest I think to start Stephens
transformation something like kind of
overall black and white kind of feel oh
okay I don't know who this guy is really
tight skinny jeans and some army boots
maybe a dress shirt with a really nice
jacket with a little bit of accessory
not too much bleaching his hair
completely gray ashy too like Cape hugs
tear piece yeah when you're a very high
flyer sexy hair I like it I like it a
lot yeah doesn't he thank you I think it
is really important to keep Steven as
who he is so to have Steven feel really
comfortable and make it seem like oh
this is neat still me but I'm just
having a new look I feel like when you
say kpop starting from makeup a lot of
k-pop artists we're like eyeliners or BB
cream so I think we could do some like
contouring on Stevens face a little
definitely hang out his structures a
little bit my want his hair up I just
got to create volume it's all about
being correct and styled really nicely I
was always told that the hair is the
crown to this overall look wow this is
incredible
that's a kpop star you're welcome
okay Steve it now you have your full
look on do you want to come out yeah but
I don't know if the world is ready I'm
scared
nervous for you oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay so this whole week I've been
practicing till like 2:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m.
dancing and singing but now I finally
actually feel like a kpop star you like
so good I'm so happy but people go down
at me that couldn't be a pop star me as
an artist like when I'm on stage it's
not just me performing and people just
singing the song with me there's also
like fan chants and this whole other fan
culture that's extremely dedicated to
that artist
oh man look at you cool thank you
this is it all my training on my heart
worst this entire week has led up to
this one moment he does nothing Crazy's
week of my life
emotionally I would be so high sometimes
just like oh I finally got the stance
move down in the next hour I would be
like devastated because I just couldn't
nail started - no you say no at the end
of this can I become a kpop star there's
no way I was so tired so hungry I lost
all connection with the outside way
and the fact that like all of this will
probably leave nowhere sounds like what
you went through emotionally is exactly
what all these trainings go through the
only other week he'll be 200 you so a
good job actually getting the video of a
lot of Chinese don't have that really
yeah good work thank you very much
and if you don't know kpop love kpop or
get to know kpop it's awesome k-pop
k-pop